being able to internalize what is your
game plan you know that you've done the
work you know that you're technically
and tactically proficient in what you
need to do so how do you remove the
white noise and pursue the signal of
your mindfulness of being present in the
moment mma is 90 mental apart from the
sixty percent that's physical
dr duncan french welcome to the show
hi mate how are you doing good to hear
from you i know it's nice to hear a
familiar northeastern voice
while we're over in the states
i know right it's uh there's nothing
like home when it comes down to it
right
originally north yorkshire yeah
harrogate nesboro region and then uh
moved to newcastle for college and uh i
kind of call newcastle home now
wow i'm gonna adopted geordie let's say
okay yeah yeah well the number of times
that i get accused of being australian
while i'm over here i was at a big
meet-up yesterday and i got accused of
being australian more times than i got
accused of being british i'm not sure if
that's a good thing or not
oh my i get i mean what i'm in my fifth
year well four years for my phd and then
now five years since i came back to the
states i get everything from south
african to australia to new zealand to
arkansas you name it
wow so you've been working with is it
over 30 professional or olympic sports
since you started
yeah i think 37 i think was the last
time i counted so yeah been
been blessed it's been good lots of lots
of variety and lots of opportunity but
yeah whether it's you know pro sport or
the olympic movement
i've been around the block let's say and
it was
three full olympic cycles with
team gb as well
yeah through the english institute of
sport which is obviously the high
performance service provider to british
olympic programs um
as well as commonwealth programs like
netball and things like that but um i
was a strength conditioning coach and
you know sports scientists through the
through the uh the english institute for
about 14 years so as you say a variety
of different um sporting backgrounds so
it's been it's been cool cool right
right now what's the common thread
between all of those have you moved into
specialities since you've been there was
it always strength and conditioning was
it performance
yeah no i mean i've always been a
strength and conditioning physical
preparation coach you know that's that's
kind of what i would call my you know my
my primary area of expertise um you know
with with some sports science weaved
into that you know i i my degrees and
things phds are in sports science and
but i certainly went around the couching
route um
and then could call upon my strength
conditioning and my sports science
throughout that so um yeah it's uh let's
say
many many hats many many strings to the
bow when you need it you know that's
kind of part of the deal so given the
fact that you've had over 30 sports that
you've worked with and then you've
stepped into the ufc
what is particularly unique about the
athletes that you work with there you've
got this broad base of experience in the
past but now you're working with a very
uh broad-ranging sport what's different
about the guys that you work with their
preparation their training
i mean listen every sport's got its own
culture um and and things that you
really resonate to and things that
you're like oh why are they doing it
like that you know and you kind of
question some of the behaviors but you
know i think i'm not bold enough to say
you know the success is because of me
it's it's you know hopefully i play or
mighty the teams i'm involved with play
a role in that you know athletes are
successful before um you know the
service providers come online and
they'll be successful long after we're
gone i think you know when you look at
all the different sports they all come
with different cultural approaches and
different kind of dogmatic mindsets in
what is good and what is bad um you know
i'm blessed right now to work with
combat athletes and obviously mma
fighters here in the ufc and uh i think
this is the one sport in in all of my
career where the challenges and the
different um
variables that go into success are so
complex um
you know this this community this group
of athletes uh you know they want to win
and um you you can harness that
motivation and that energy and then i
think that's one thing which really
differentiates combat athletes it's just
a commitment to the grind um any any
elite athlete at the highest level is
doing things that are
you know
are different to the normal joe blow
walking down the street right but i
think when you look at the rigors of
what mma is and what these guys go
through on a day-to-day basis it truly
has a lot to behold and i think that's
that's what's fascinating about this
community you know they are spitting
sawdust and and pretty honest as a days
long but they uh
you know that their commitment and their
dedication to their craft and their
ethic is uh
is is on founder and it's amazing would
you say that the mma fighters are
about as ultimate of an athlete as
you're going to get at the moment coming
out of sport
yeah i mean again i'm biased right
because i sit in this space right now
but again you look at gymnasts or divers
and the you know the skill and the
artistry is amazing you can take any
sport and you can pull things from it
but just in terms of you know true
athleticism and what an mma fight i have
to do by combining strength power
conditioning skill um the psychological
component of being able to execute under
what is you know truly severe and
consequential outcomes um really
differentiates them and and it's funny
because i get a lot of other athletes or
athletes i've worked with formally
reaching out to me and say oh you know a
big fan of the ufc or um i think that's
kind of a measure when you have other
pro athletes saying like i love watching
mma and the ufc and those guys are
unreal what they can do and okay well if
you're saying that then
there's obviously something in it which
is uh which is pretty cool to hear yeah
it's such an entertaining sport you know
the guys have really really got this
format right which is
it's it's two guys or two girls
in a eight-sided ring
smashing seven shades of [ __ ] out of
each other uh for a while and then as
someone's hand gets raised at the end of
it it's a fairly simple format but it is
so
accessible super entertaining i think
the build up that they've got now um at
first i wasn't much of a fan of the
cleaning up of the branding but i think
that that also makes everything look a
lot more cleaner and and professional
which is great um going back to what you
said before about the fact that there
has been an influence of your input the
performance institute on the outcomes
that you're getting from the fighters
but because you are dealing with every
fighter the water line of all of them
gets raised up right like everybody has
access to you guys now not everybody's
going to get the same sort of outcomes
because not everybody's as coachable not
everybody responds as well they might
have more dogmatic ideologies within
their own gym and such like but
how are you um gauging the impact that
you have across the board across all
fighters when everybody has access it's
not like the ufc beat
some other organization in a big battle
royale
uh it's a little bit different to any
professional sporting organization where
you're judged on wins and losses um for
all intents and purposes right um we're
we're kind of the league let's say um
and we'll only have about 500 because we
might be working with both athletes that
are in the octagon at the same time for
a main event well you've never lost a
fight
yeah right we've never
we've never lost a fight we've also
won a lot as well right
i lost a lot of excuse me i mean um i
think uh you know our evaluation of our
success is based on different kind of
kpis and objectives it comes down to um
you know what you said at the head of
your question yes the performance
institute is about raising the level
across the whole fight community
globally that's a that's a big ambition
right um but it's about slowly evolving
the sport to embed you know better
training science better methodologies
better approaches for medicine or
nutrition or whatever it may be you know
the nature of injuries and the incidence
of injuries and how they're happening
around a a wrestling practice that might
have too many athletes on the mat at one
time and you know wrestling scramble and
someone might roll onto another pair
working somewhere else on the mat and
you cause a stupid injury that's
completely preventable you know those
type of things we kind of try and keep
an eye on um looking at how
athletes are making weight and the
status of their weight making exercises
and it does is it done in a in
an optimized fashion you know ultimately
we're in a weight classification sport
which in itself is a cultural approach
not every sport requires you to make
weight that brings with it a lot of
nuance and a lot of tradition and
approaches so how do we kind of get the
athletes into the octagon in the most
optimal way possible um
around the parameters of making weight
and the guys having to cut weights
um and then other things like you know
some of the performance metrics like is
the show entertaining the technical
skills that have been executed we take a
lot of interest in that as well because
ultimately by association whilst we're
not necessarily the ones coaching those
techniques or the technical tactical
side of it giving people physical
attributes or a mental status to go and
try a technique in competition or um you
know as i say optimizing someone's
capability during competition you you
would say that the probability of
the fight being um at a higher level at
a higher standard has also got some
influence by the work that we're doing
as well yeah one of the things that's
interesting is if you look back to the
traditions of fighting you know your
bruce lee's the very much a sort of
savant artistic interpretation you had
more
uh
eastern martial arts that would involve
things like energy cheese such like
how are you finding the blend because i
i'm presuming you can't have completely
got rid and there's also you know the
the sort of fighters that are very much
flow and natural and artistic in the way
that they fight how are you finding the
blend between this artistic element and
the data driven in in interventions that
you need to make with people
yes great question um i mean i think
first and foremost it's it's martial
arts right it's mixed martial arts and
whilst it'd say it's a competitive fight
and you know that that's chaos often um
you know you'd be surprised the
underpinning techniques and tactics that
go into
into the fight any moment in time um and
again i draw on you know
something that's been brought into our
ecosystem here the performance institute
through our
head mma coach over at shanghai academy
dinamo singer he talks about um the mfa
which is the martial artists or the m
the you know they're martial artists
they are fighters and then they are also
athletes all right so fma like we we
look at that kind of trifecta of
influence so when it comes to you know
the artistry the tactics the the
technical skill set you know a lot of
our guys still draw on bruce lee and and
you know some of those pure martial art
sets
and then yeah athleticism we can put a
lot of data and objectivity around
athleticism so whether it is martial
arts being a fighter which is momental
and and some physical attributes but
then also the physical attributes of
athleticism and being an athlete we can
start to really nail down each of these
three factors that go into um you know
driving success in our sport talking
about some of the tensions that might be
going on between the way that people
typically see
fighters particularly those that do mma
and the new world or this sort of
renaissance that you guys are getting
with data-driven interventions and stuff
and trying to professionalize all of
this
how are you finding managing the
relationship between your team and the
guys that you look after and the
interventions that they want and then
the
uh athletes the fighters coach and the
gym that they go back to or the multiple
gyms that they might go back to
afterwards they're gonna have their
ideas around how they should be
preparing how they should be training
their loading et cetera et cetera um
talk to me about the tension between
those
yeah i think you talk about tension i
think you gotta try and remove the
tension and that that's any sport right
and again i draw on my experiences and
it doesn't matter what sport you go into
it comes down to you know the maturity
of people to handle data and handle
information now for some sports that
have got you know
legacy and long-term history of using
wearable technology or handling data
looking at statistics and measuring uh
you know you take a sport like
basketball everything's built or
american football everything's built
around statistics baseball is probably
the most classic one there
so they're really comfortable in using
and talking about numbers and using
numbers to direct strategy other sports
might not necessarily be as mature in
handling data and be comfortable with
that type of information mixed martial
arts being one of them so what we're
trying to do is obviously elevate
people's awareness and understanding of
the types of information we're giving
them um you know you can look to the
recent kind of evolution of leg kicks or
low calf kicks in mma and how it's kind
of revolutionizing our sports as
something that's really pivoted the
sport and taking it down a different
direction i mean
calf kicks have always been around but
they've not been used as much as they
are now and they're truly debilitating
right so it's becoming a real tact an
offensive tactic but you've also got to
be defending against that so you know
out there in the community the coaches
are innovating at any moment in time but
what we're trying to do is is kind of
put evidence and evaluation against it
to say you know how can we optimize it
further how can we give you competitive
competitive advantage and try and come
together and meet the rubber where where
it meets the road with
the the maturity of an athlete or a
coach to handle information yeah
how do you deal with the fact that
typically you have a strength and
conditioning or a coaching unit that is
looking after one team and every athlete
that works underneath them is being
pushed forward whereas you are doing
opponent fighter and opponent now
obviously there'll be securities around
data and such like it's like you're
going to be telling each fighter what
the other one's preparing and stuff like
that but that must be a very unique
uh environment to work in right where
you are like we said before you win and
lose every single fight that you've been
involved in
right yeah i mean we're agnostic to the
whole roster so you're absolutely right
you know athlete the the model that we
work to is that the ufc fighters are
independent contractors so we can't
mandate that they engage with the
performance institute and the services
that we offer um it's very much an a la
carte take it or leave it pick what you
want type approach and obviously that
drives individuality from the very
get-go some athletes want all of our
service provision some athletes want
nothing to do with us because there's a
lot of paranoia about what you're
talking about in this question other
athletes will pick and choose bits and
pieces as and when they see fit you know
if you've got a
uh some kind of injury or historical
injury that we're working and treating
with you you know obviously your
opponent
doesn't you know that's that information
is sacrosanct if your opponent was to
find that out that could truly change
the the likelihood of your success in
the event so yeah we're very sensitive
to how we handle information how we
handle data and knowing that we've got
this really kind of wild and unique
business model that we work to where
we're potentially working with two
fighters that are going to compete in a
month's time and we're strategizing and
working with their coaches helping them
on physical development etc etc i think
you know the the thing that we do to
distance ourselves completely for that
is that we don't coach and teach
technical and tactical work through the
performance institute which is obviously
the secret source um you know the mma
techniques what we do is obviously
support them with you know nutrition and
body composition with diagnostics with
physical preparation with mental
preparation all those supplementary
factors not necessarily the true things
which are going to influence the outcome
of the fight which is technical tactical
work so we kind of align ourselves to
that but we don't deliver that
specifically what are the primary
metrics that you're looking at over the
uh weeks and months so my housemate has
just been given a promotion at newcastle
falcons he's now the junior physio of
the first team uh and
since living with him for the last few
years i've been fascinated learning
about chronic loads uh and uh yardage
and i got to see the back end of one of
the spreadsheets that they have these
readouts and it's just an endless
endless stream of data who got the up to
the maximum velocity this week who's
done the most yard all this stuff so
what's the equivalent in your world what
do you look at from the players
yeah i mean welcome to the world of like
world-class store elite level sport
right now i mean there's more data than
we all know what to do with because
ultimately technology has changed the
game
and as soon as you start wearing
technology and competition
and training and you're aggregating all
this magic i mean just just kind of
processing that in a team setting can
can be overwhelming um but i think when
we look at you know mma obviously
we're trying to get to the same
questions we're trying to understand how
you optimize training load the exposure
to a training stimulus to maximize the
effect of that training stimulus so how
how do we do that how do we measure
people's exposure and what's the right
expo it's a goldilocks effect right how
much is too much how much is too little
and oh goldilocks that's just right
exactly that's what we need to be um
there's a lot of research and literature
out there that we know connection
between the the the likelihood of injury
or an injury incidence
with over training versus under training
versus you know where things sit so
that's an important conversation but in
the sport of mma it's a little bit
different right because um
we don't have um really robust data
insights around competition our fighters
not like they're wearing heart rate
monitors it's not like they're wearing
gps it's not like they were in any kind
of accelerometers or those types of
things where we can really start to
understand what competition is
we're kind of extrapolating a little bit
and making insinuations based on what we
the data we can get in sparring or in
training so yeah we look at trading load
we look at you know vision assessments
and reaction times we look at cognitive
function obviously it's a you know a
sport where you're getting hit in the
head so how do we monitor and manage
those those exposure loads whether it's
through instrumented mouthpieces that
have accelerometers in them where we can
look no way whether you can put
something in the mouth that's going to
measure everything
oh yeah yeah that's that's kind of the
direction we're going now
i've already
yeah in in rugby and australian rules
football it's already happening a little
bit we're in you know we're pursuing
that with mma
um and then you've obviously got other
factors like um
you know just his strength power
characteristics heart rate for your
conditioning what's your training zone
what's your biological load with respect
to lactate management things like that
so i mean listen to answer the question
it's it's a lot of different things um
in support of mma we still haven't
nailed down what competition truly is so
that we can reverse engineer everything
from competition so that's the north
star for us right now is working with
different partners and technology and
academics to say all right how can we
really nail down an understanding of
what mma is um because we haven't got
those insights and obviously there's the
striking components but there's
grappling components where you're not
really moving too much but there's a
huge metabolic demand through isometric
hold or isometric contraction that it's
really hard to classify what that looks
like in terms of ultimately the athletic
load that you have to
you know perform in the octagon i went
to this meetup that i said yesterday
where i got accused of being an
australian and at it i uh i met this guy
who spends eight hours a day in virtual
reality so he's at the forefront of
um like developing
games yeah he seemed to love it but um
and he was telling me that there is um
new vr technology that is able to track
uh the body's position in space so that
it can accurately represent it in the
virtual reality world i'm wondering
whether you would be able to get to the
stage in future where all of the
different camera angles that you guys
have around the octagon may be able to
track stuff like trauma and movement um
and then be able to reverse engineer
that to actually be able to give you
some sort of metrics but the fact that
you've got whatever
a gps mouth guard with an inbuilt hrv
monitor or a heart rate sensor in it
that blows my mind you could have
something that you just knock into knock
into your mouth and give you all of
those solutions is crazy
yeah it's cool right and again that's
one piece of equipment and technology
that they wear in training and
competition so you know that that's
that's something that we're pursuing
because it can be universal then um but
yeah i mean you talk about vr like
anything that mitigates you know tbi or
concussion or the risk of head trauma in
our sport is going to be beneficial and
advantageous um so we we're actively
pursuing those types of things um and
yeah vr virtual reality augmented
reality in a combat environment along
with haptic technology where you look at
vibration so you know it's coming out of
the gaming world you know world of
warcraft or whatever or cards you know
those types of things where you you know
you shoot your gun but you're getting
that feedback as well at the same time
how can we apply haptic technology in a
uh augmented reality space where we're
using vr and we're also getting haptic
feedback to say you suggested you're
getting hit or you know a punch or
something but you're actually not um
you know those are types of training
strategies kind of moving into the
future that we're always also exploring
dude this is your 3000 [ __ ] it's so
advanced
did i hear you once mentioned that you
guys were looking at some of the
potential impacts of psychedelics as a
performance enhancer
not as a performance enhancer but around
traumatic brain injury also it's like a
neuroprotective type
correct yeah and you know there's
there's been some good work particularly
out of um john hopkins university over
in maryland um where they're looking at
um you know blessed you know terminal
patients and patients with you know um
you know certain
medical conditions that are going to be
terminal at some point so how do they
use psychedelics to relieve pain or
remove um you know and again in kind of
combat populations where they looked at
post-traumatic stress disorders and
depression and some of these aspects on
a very clinical level how psychedelics
have potentially um
an opportunity to to influence that
again it's very early days for the ufc
it's not something that we're completely
um you know running down this avenue
right now but again looking at working
with partners to cover every avenue to
see where yes we know that we we operate
in a combat sport right there are
certain um you know issues and factors
related to combat sport within the
parameters about the rules of the sport
well yes it's a it's a collision and
it's a contact sport it's going to lead
to certain physical um psychological
social emotional impacts that um might
have a detrimental effect so whether
it's a um
a rule change whether it's equipment
that you wear whether it's um
interventions like psychedelics or like
nutritional interventions or norotropics
or whatever it may be you know i think
we're just very engaged in trying to
understand that and take them on so that
we can do a better job of keeping
athletes in the in the hell in the most
safe and healthy space possible
how much do you deal with the um
psychological strain so i'm fascinated
by the fact that you're asking your
athletes and this is the same with every
fight i mean it's the same with every
sport in general but particularly with a
fight sport where
there's so much glory around success
there's so much not shame around defeat
but you can see in the player's body
language or the fighters body language
right at the end of the fight plus there
is fight week leading up to it there's
press conferences there's [ __ ] talking
beforehand there's weight cuts there's
it's such a unique
blend of psychological strain which is
precisely designed at least by your
opponent that way right to put you in a
a place where you're not actually all
that
confident um how much have you looked at
strategies for how the guys can deal
with this and are there any lessons that
people could take away uh into their own
lives for in the build up to a stressful
situation or something that they're
perhaps a little bit anxious about
yeah that's a that's a great question um
and again listen we're remember we're a
promotion right um and these guys are
independent independent contractors so
they're in the business of promoting
themselves to get you know people to buy
tickets to come and watch them so
whether it's [ __ ] talking or whether
it's promotion like this they're trying
to sell the event and get people
interested in their fight um
you know
you know without letting you behind the
curt too much you know some of that's
obviously real some of it's bravado um
but again it makes for a makes for an
interesting build up to the fight itself
um yeah i mean from a psychological or
sports psychology perspective we're
absolutely getting into that space
because it's a it's a pillar of
performance so how do athletes manage
that how do they use it and to their
advantage how do they stay away from
someone else
and doing it and
i think we when we first started the
performance institute back in 2017 we
didn't have sports psychology as part of
our portfolio of services it's
absolutely a critical core component now
and we offer that to uh to the athletes
um
but yeah i think you know to answer it
succinctly
um you know we do a lot of work around
kind of mindfulness and being able to
disassociate from all that white noise
and being able to internalize what is
your game plan you know that you've done
the work you know that you're
technically and tactically proficient in
what you need to do so how do you remove
the white noise and pursue the signal of
your mindfulness of being present in the
moment now
present in the moment in in the ufc can
be someone kind of seven seconds from
choking you out so um you know you still
gotta be mindful and present at that
moment but again it comes down to right
what's the technique what's the tactic i
need to actually execute to remove this
choke um
there's so many pieces of white noise
and chaos and and um you know so many
factors and i think you know
to succinctly give you an answer when we
look at our psychologists in the way
work that they do and with our athletes
it's very much around being present and
be mindful and being able to process
things effectively otherwise it those
external signals just overwhelm yeah
yeah it's um
it's strange to think about the number
of parameters that go into
someone putting a good performance on
in ufc like it's so unbelievably
intense to balance all of these
different elements and something that
i've always thought about is
the number of athletes out there in any
domain who physically may have the
character physiologically may have the
characteristics to make them an
unbelievably elite athlete they may have
the approach to training they may have
the genetics they may have the work rate
the conscientiousness the
industriousness the support system
everything
however
they are unable to deal with the stress
of game day and i wonder how many
athletes throughout the years have got
themselves to the stage where they were
they they could have been a world chat
they could have been the greatest that
ever lived and they were let down by
their inability to kind of get out of
their own heads and allow themselves to
perform on game day
yeah
and you know the stakes are pretty high
in this sport this is like i say it's a
sport of consequences right and the
consequence every sport has got
consequences um but in this sport they
can be pretty severe right um so that
just layers on kind of the pressures and
the stresses and uh
we we just hear the pi but we say you
know it that mma is 90 mental apart from
the 60 that's physical you know i mean
like it's it's just everything you need
everything in this sport and again
coming back to one of your early
questions like it's really hard to you
know there's so many variables right so
it's really hard to say one is any more
important than the other but when it
comes to mental fortitude and that's
even before you get into competition
like the mental fortitude just to get
through the rigors of training on a
daily basis to you know hit hit the mix
and then do your strength conditioning
work on the side like just a mental
fortitude to be compliant and and um
you know adhere to a long-term approach
to technical and tactical development as
well as physical development that alone
is is challenging in our sport now you
can liken that to things like you know
rowing or rugby codes or whatever it may
be which are also very physical but then
yeah you layer on that psychological
piece of you're walking into competition
and there's millions watching on tv and
you're potentially going to get knocked
out and people are going to ridicule you
and laugh at you while
on
you're
right which is which is you know
shocking you know these underpants you
know internet warriors um
it's easy to point fingers so you know
that that's where i come back to like
our athletes are up there with with the
best of them when it comes to their
ability to um to deal with all the
variables that go into success it's
pretty you know it's truly a decathlon
of combat sport and it's pretty crazy
have you worked with rowing
yeah a lot well one of the things that i
think about there is the
i i've done 2k row time tests before and
the
state of arousal that i get myself of
fear basically that i get myself into
before have it before having to do that
um
what were some of the lessons that you
got out of the time that you worked with
rowers because you know there's some of
the events that they do which are and
some of the training sessions that i've
do i always find the um
oxford cambridge rowing event the lead
up to that you know where they go
through the training montages and they
explain what everyone's going through it
looks
up there with some of the most brutal
training protocols that i've ever seen
is that is that what it's actually like
yeah absolutely i mean rowan can be yeah
the the the the physical demands of
elite level rowing um and the physical
and physiological adaptations that
you're trying to make to your body and
training uh are massive right so yeah
those guys push themselves to the
absolute limit you know that and i've
been around some of those sessions and
it's just terrifying and brutal to watch
you know someone's not kind of stomping
on your head then or someone's not going
to come and trying to truly knock you
out um
like i say it's
and i'm not playing down kind of rowing
or anything or any other sport i'm just
saying i think when you look at all the
respective factors and the outcome of
our sport what people are trying to do
to you and inflict physical damage to
you as well um
it just makes it just layers on another
kind of level of intensity and i'm not
using that as a physical intensive just
like intensity of everything because
yeah rowan rowan is the training for
rowan to be an elite level rower is is
brutal um
but yeah these guys are doing it and
that and they've got this 2k 2k road
test with someone trying to punch you in
the face while you do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i have um so i met
a couple of guys who were recently on a
reality tv
program for a grappling and upcoming
grappling competition that was going on
and it was kind of like a an ultimate
fighter style thing to living in a fight
house and they were going out and doing
their whatever and they were playing
pranks on each other
in between and stuff like that and they
had
in order to get through to one of the
next rounds
they had a no time limit
uh grappling event which i
i had never heard of before but isn't
unbelievably rare apparently in in that
world and um
one of the fights that the the dude that
was traveling to this event in san
antonio with us
had lasted for three hours and 55
minutes
of grappling
three hours and 55 minutes of graphics
think about that i mean just processing
that is ridiculous right you're
essentially
um
you know grappling and trying to you
know submit or choke out an opponent the
same duration it takes someone to run a
marathon you know i mean it it's just
almost unfathomable but that's what
these guys will do
and the warrior spirit will you know
will take them through that dude it's
unbelievable i am i was really really
impressed but it's one of those things
where you realize
just how big of a delta there is between
everybody sits on the sidelines and
talks about like oh well you know
you should slip that punch and you
should do this in a different way
because everybody feels like they have
some sort of five pens to add into the
discussion around things you realize
there is
it's a different universe these people
are
completely different animals so speaking
of that are there some fighters that
you've worked with or that you've seen
in the performance institute either sort
of current roster or previous roster
that are just a total joy to coach or
people that have come in with a a very
particular um physiology that you found
that's that's unique or different or
impressive that you hadn't seen
previously
i mean i i talking in well i'll answer
your question yes it's funny right
because um
i've worked with all these different
sports but you know
there's one thing which the armchair
expert always knows and that's fighting
and nutrition right and here we are i'm
working in the sport where there's and
the same thing everyone seems to be an
expert in how you win a fight you know
what i mean so it's like there's a lot
of there's a lot of noise and a lot of
people
in this
yeah in this world um you know you cut
through that i think like i said i come
back to the clientele the athlete
population like the the
in my experience you know whilst there's
different polarizing characters in our
sport
talking generically like this is a group
of athletes that i just love working
with that like they want to get after it
they want to do the work they're not
scared of the work they are committed to
you know the cause and to the arts and
all that type of stuff and um
yeah i mean
absolute pleasure to work with of course
they've got quirks and traits like come
on man that's what the [ __ ] are you
doing that like why are you doing that
but i mean at the end of the day as a
group of athletes i i would work with
combat athletes any day of the week when
i've looked at some of my other athletes
and again whether it's you know premier
league soccer or you know where athletes
position in the pecking order and the
hierarchy of things but combat athletes
are
absolute joy and pleasure to work with
um certainly on the physical preparation
side because you're not having to
convince them to do the work usually um
you're pulling the horses back and
saying you know what hold on like enough
is enough like let's let's uh just think
about this strategically so um yeah i
mean i i don't want to mention any
particular names but there's uh there's
lots of individuals on our roster who um
like absolute warriors true first class
people whether they've come from olympic
backgrounds through freestyle wrestling
in the olympic games so whether they
come through collegiate programs or
whether they're talent transfers from
football like american football um
whether just guys have been on the fight
circuit and journeyman that have been
knocking people out you know for year
over year and just like okay this is a
guy that might not be the best athlete
but he's just a hard individual and a
hard human being just even those guys
like great to be around because you can
learn so much from their mindset and
their mentality of how they approach
life right it's fascinating
so going into some of the training
protocols and stuff that you use that
people at home may be able to take on i
know that you've done a lot of research
around optimal reps set ranges
rest periods in order to maximize muscle
growth and hypertrophy what have you
come to what sort of conclusion have you
come to at the moment with that
yeah i mean the irony is that um we
don't pursue a lot of hypertrophy um
training techniques in combat athletes
because usually they're having to make
weight um so you know we're not trying
to put excessive amounts of muscle on an
athlete in in the rare chance we do if
someone moves up a weight class or if
someone's kind of still you know
chronically under fueled or whatever it
may be
we try and pursue some of those types of
things but yeah i mean i think the key
things to hypertrophy
uh obviously you know looking at muscle
damage how you insure muscle damage
you're kind of the three pillars of
hypertrophy
so using different training approaches
whether it be cluster sets whether it be
drop sets whether it be pause reps
whether it be eccentrics accentuated
eccentrics whatever there's a different
way to do that so there's no like
perfect method for creating hypertrophy
but you know looking at time under
tension is a volume conversation it's
it's how much time tension can you put
through a muscle within a working set so
you know larger rep ranges and set
ranges obviously or the number of times
within a week
so kind of looking at um you know 12 to
30 sets for a given muscle group in a
training week is where you're trying to
pursue hypertrophy and looking at how
you
damage tissue because then it can regrow
and redevelop
you know to a greater level and so
rebuild larger so how do you use
techniques like eccentrics
that are going to promote some tissue
damage to allow it to then regenerate
and recover when you say when you say
eccentrics are you talking about tempo
movements basically there
correct yeah yeah yeah yes like you know
slowly centered so concentric shortening
actions versus eccentric lengthening
actions which we know damage the muscle
more and then also creating a metabolic
stimulus like what's the internal
environment whether it's nitric oxide
that you're trying to release and that's
where some of this uh you know blood
flow restriction is now quite vogue in
hypertrophy training you know that's
just trying to create a metabolic stress
inside the cell
and then obviously the critical thing in
parallel to those three factors is
nutrition is protein and protein
synthesis and looking at um you know the
the protein synthetic rate of muscle how
how muscle can turn over protein and are
you fueling your butt excuse me right
wrong term are you providing kind of the
the building blocks um and usually that
is you know leucine is is the key amino
acid um for muscle growth and muscle
hypertrophy that we need to think about
um but are you kind of putting your
nutrition strategy
in a very complementary fashion with the
training strategy and a training
stimulus that is going to affect those
three factors yeah what are the big
mistakes that people are making when it
comes to that sort of uh perry training
nutrition
strategy
well i think a lot of the the science a
lot of research obviously is around
nutrient timing um and you know i think
particularly around a uh
around a training session you try you
need to get the protein in as close to
the cessation of
the end of your your workout as possible
all right because that's when the you
know protein synthetic rate is going to
be at its highest
and the reason this is a protein and the
rebuilding of the amino acids is going
to be at its highest level so
providing those building blocks through
a nutrition intervention is going to be
critical if you leave it too long
obviously you're just
negating or mitigating the extent of
protein synthesis that's going to happen
so that's kind of the key thing um and
yeah anywhere between kind of 0.25 to
0.3 of a gram per kilo of body weight
per day is um is what you're looking at
from a protein stimulus or a protein
intake for uh hypertrophy strategies
0.25 to 0.3
of a gram
per kilo of body weight
post what is that just around the
workout
today
i'm trying to work out because surely
that would be whatever 40 grams or 30
grams of protein per day
correct
but that's not total intake
no no not all intake yes
in terms of supplementary protein right
okay yeah it's so interesting it's so
funny that there was that sort of back
in the day the the bro science around
where you need to get your post workout
shake in as quickly after a training
session as possible and then again
you're talking to
people that get their information from
bodybuilding.com forums right and like
meme pages from reddit and stuff like
that but uh that was something that was
i think about five years ago very widely
dispelled as if it fits your macros it
doesn't really matter calories or
calories and then when we actually go
and speak to somebody that's at the
cutting edge of elite sport it turns out
that well maybe the the bros in the
beginning were right all along
evidence-based research and
research-based evidence right and i
think it's you know
a lot of sports techniques and sports
training have been
built on anecdotal insights and people
trying out techniques and then you know
the science has followed and put
efficacy against some of those some of
those uh original methods and clearly
it's also um
you know made other approaches and other
methods less than efficacious and
they've been kind of phased out so uh
yeah it's what's leading the narrative
the science or the practice is always
the question
talking about something that i never
ever considered uh during training
because it's just it felt like something
that was too complex and too sort of
forward thinking about the hormone
release effect that you get from
different types of training stimulus and
let's say that it's for somebody that's
just trying to keep themselves fit and
look good and you know be healthy and
maybe gain a little bit of muscle and
keep themselves at whatever body fat
level or perhaps even try and recomp a
little bit um i'd never considered
the
impact of different training
methodologies on the hormone profile
that's going in my body can you hear
about the fact that you get growth
hormone release from heavy compound
movements and you get testosterone
released from such and such
what is
for the normal lay person that's just
looking to train
what are the things that they should
consider when it comes to optimizing
hormone release
through their training methodology
well i mean i think it's it's important
to understand like this metabolic
stimulus right as we've talked about
time under tension we've talked about
muscle damage and then obviously the
metabolic stimulus the metabolic
environment that's created within the
muscle so you know this is what my phd
work was around so um you know this is
where kind of some of my messaging has
come through from in this space and but
yeah again it comes back to how you
stimulate intensities of or volumes of
workload to create that metabolic
stimulus of which a uh endocrine cascade
is part of the the equation it's not the
whole equation obviously um what do you
mean when you say endocrine cascade well
just the release of hormones
consequent to uh consequent to you know
muscle stimulus or metabolic out um so
how do the hormones get
certain types of stimulus you do
a trending um program that is you know
five sets of two with three minutes in
between each set it's going to be a very
diff different metabolic stimulus to um
four sets of 12 with uh 60 seconds rest
between right so you know that that's
the the challenge of training and
training strategies understanding um
what is it of those three factors that
you're trying to stimulate um i think
metabolic stimulus and you know hormonal
responses is a part of that conversation
so
when you're trying to maximize
hypertrophy and you're trying to
maximize those three particular factors
um then potentially there's some some
likes to consider in what you do to
stimulate hormone release as well so
you're looking at intensity as one of
the key factors for this
yes intensity and volume yeah intensive
value because again if you look at
training intensity and how hard you're
pushing a muscle or the contractual
units of of you of the muscle and that's
going to have a certain stimulus you
know you can play on that those two
factors
by creating training strategies by they
um may be different workouts within a
given week or within a specific workout
where you're targeting those two things
at the same time again the the end point
is that you're trying to stimulate a
stress response and that might have or
will have kind of some beneficial
effects um to promote muscle growth
within the cell
i've heard you say is it six sets of ten
at eighty percent with a couple of
minutes rest in between as one of the
protocols that you use
yeah i mean that was very much for my
phd um research yeah six sets of ten um
with uh
with a with a minute's rest in between
ultimately
sorry 90 seconds in between excuse me 90
seconds in between but do that as drop
sets so you're always trying to retain
the you start a load of 80 of your 1rm
but the key thing is to hit the 10
repetition um
requirement of each set so you
essentially can do a drop set so
that you can un take the load um you
might not be able to complete the set of
10 your racket you immediately unload
and you finish off the remaining
repetitions to complete your ten sets so
yeah it's a pretty challenging and
brutal approach to uh a training
stimulus
it's [ __ ] absolutely possessed like
it does i can't think of a more
disgusting
training problem because what i hadn't
heard the first time that i heard you
say that i hadn't heard about the the
stripping of weights either like intra
set or a cross set um so i'm thinking
who can do
by ten at eighty percent who can do ten
you can do one by ten at eighty percent
um with especially with the short rest
normally you get two two sets out um at
eighty percent or so but then yeah the
into the potentially second or third or
beyond sets you you really start to
strip the bar back because then again
like i say that's now becomes the the
volume conversation it's about using the
drop sets of the load to complete the
the required volume uh am i guessing
that if you were to do an rpe you'd be
looking at like an rp 9.5 by the end of
each set
i mean
yeah because it can't be a 10 or else
you're not going to have made oh i guess
it would be a 10 but you're not going to
have gone above a 10 because otherwise
you wouldn't have made those repetitions
right
i mean a 10 on rpa scale is maximal
right so you would want maximum because
if you only do four repetitions you
unload you might get another two
repetitions out you unload again you
might get another three repetitio like
that's how you work in the the stimulus
right so it's always trying to be
maximal in in nature okay and with this
did you find that certain exercises
engendered themselves to better hormone
release i'm going to guess larger
movements more muscle groups being
recruited
what were the best exercises
i think that's the secret to all like
hypertrophy type approaches is that yeah
multiple large compound exercises and
more muscle activation
okay yeah so i mean
well i might i might see if some of the
lads in the gym fancy doing it tomorrow
but i i it's they're gonna take a little
bit i'll get them to listen to this
first and i'll tell them about your
credentials and we'll see we'll see what
they can say talking about recovery
between sessions and especially with
your guys right because you've got so
many different domains that the fighters
need to be able to move through it's not
just technique stuff it's not just
strength and conditioning it's not just
the cardio all of these different bits
and pieces what have you found is an
upper bound
that you can get
say the average elite fighter i'm aware
that that person doesn't particularly
exist um what's the upper bound in terms
of a training
volume you know duration per day that
you can get people
through uh i mean i'll answer a little
bit differently i i mean
we recommend kind of anywhere between 10
and 14 training units a week um but
there's guys that are absolutely doing
upwards of 18 to 20 training units a
week um you know there's there's a
conversation on quality right it's a
quality and quantity conversation um
some uh
you know some sessions you know are
going to be 60 to 90 minutes long but
there's also fighters that'll pull three
hour long training sessions and think
you know don't think twice about it so
it's uh that's where we don't have the
answers right now we don't understand
kind of what is the true optimal level
what's the true um you know the true
standard approach that we put in place
um and we're still trying to figure that
out through kind of monitoring and
evaluating training kind of loads and
people's ability to tolerate that i've
got a bunch of friends who are
chasing for a crossfit games or a
crossfit regionals spot at the moment
and i think that there are some
similarities probably between your guys
these sports just that they're
very wide in terms of the different
domains and the different stimuluses
that you're trying to get out of all of
the different training protocols that
people do and there you know i'll say
hey man send me because i just like to
be a sort of a voyeuristic uh torturer
and i'll say but send me what your
training
week
looks like and you see it's up at 7 00
am for a
hour and a half swim it's back i'll go
i'll have a nap until the morning time
i'll do some strength work and maybe
some honest structural work then i'll go
back have some more food then i'll go
you're thinking like this is you know
multiple days per week and their active
recovery days
look like
just a slightly lower intensity version
of a longer workout that i might try and
do and um
yeah it's yeah i mean if you think of
something like if you think of something
like crossfit which has got you know
potentially many different components to
it whether you're working on your
strength or your olympic lifts or
whether you're working on handstand
walks or you know and swimming you know
now bringing swimming into the crossfit
game like so you know you don't know
what's going to happen in the crossfit
games right so you're always preparing
for the unknown by just ticking every
single box
that's the same as mma you've got lots
of different variables that you need to
kind of complete the training exposure
in um so how do you distribute that
you're either stacking sessions on top
of each other and making very long
sessions and then having more prolonged
you know rest periods or you're doing
you know distributing of training blocks
throughout the day in a very sporadic
nature to try and
capture some recovery after each workout
it's it's you know again it's
we don't really have that figured out in
its entirety right now a lot of that
down to personal preference at the
moment
yeah absolutely absolutely and also you
know the the personal lifestyles of the
fighter you know they
got to pick the kids up for from school
or something like that yeah some
fighters have full-time jobs as
pipeliners or electricians or whatever
as well as doing all the training you
know demetrius johnson who's obviously
uh you know 125 in the ufc for a long
time now fights in a different
organization but uh he you know holds
the records for most defenses in 125. he
was um a full-time um contractor you
know builder and and worked on a
building site whilst at the same time
doing his uh his mma training so what
would you say if you were to try and
characterize some of the attributes
between the guys that joined the ufc who
are you know obviously elite fighters
they've managed to get themselves an
invite into the organization um and
the difference between the ones that
come and go uh and are unable to have
that longevity and unable to unable to
really make it to the actual absolute
elite of the sport and become not
necessarily champions because that's
beyond just
their own internal training and approach
the sport
but
between those guys and between the guys
that do make it to the absolute top and
then also have the longevity as well in
terms of characteristics their approach
to whatever it be maybe training
coaching all that sort of stuff
yeah i mean i think as well as well if
you're in the ufc you're not training
harder than anybody else everybody
trains hard in this sport right i think
if you look at the true elite guys what
they have the ability to do is get back
on the mats every single day so the
thing that differentiates the people at
the top versus everybody else is their
ability to truly train at the highest
highest level from a technical tactical
perspective day after day after day
after day
you know for chronic periods of time
whereas everyone else might you know
reduce their training capabilities and
then rebound a little bit um
still training hard obviously but i
think that's one thing which we look to
in in our kind of conversations here is
something that truly is is
differentiating the top guys just their
ability to go again and again and again
on a daily basis or session to session
such that the technical input
to their training and their skill
development is that much greater than
everybody else's
have you had a look at motivation
from
we're getting into that a little bit
early days if i'm honest yeah we and
again people are very motivated for
different reasons to be fighters right
so
you know we'll think that you know the
the people that just want to um
you know beat up other folk
but that's not always the case you know
some people are using it as a very
meditative type approach to like what
what you know physical pain and trauma
allows them to release themselves other
people are coming at it because you know
they just love the martial arts and
they're lifelong martial artists other
people coming at it from um you know
just financials and i'm just providing
money for my kids right so i think the
motivation again is very very complex um
and we haven't we're starting to look
into that but we haven't got that you
know it's so diverse in the way people
arrive at success in our sport yeah it's
a a question that i think a lot of other
people want to have answered as well let
alone just ufc fighters it is
interesting to think about the fact that
a lot of different athletes can arrive
in the same sport
at the absolute elite of it and yet be
driven by completely different things
that you and me can both be fighting in
the ufc and you're doing it because you
just love to scrap and that's what you
always did and that's your passion and
i'm doing it because it's a meditative
experience and the next person that
we're going to fight is doing it because
he wants to provide for his family or
whatever
yeah
absolutely and i think you know it's
another reason to be fascinated by our
sport like the diversity
and the just the the different variables
that come into what makes uh you know
to define what a world champion is in
mixed martial arts is like
throwing mud at a wall and seeing what
sticks because you know you could have
like truly world-class athletes that are
coming out of olympic programs or
whatever you could have a guy that's
just been around the streets you know
like knocking people out for a long time
and has elevated to the to the top of
small level promotions through to you
know kids today at 18 years old are
training mma from the get-go and so
they're just that i'm a mixed martial
artist rather now i'm a kickboxer or i'm
a wrestler it that's kind of the cool
part of it it's just the diversity and
the complexity of people's backgrounds
and how do you say that this one route
is any better than someone else's route
to the top you know have you got any
idea i think about this a lot to do with
crossfit because it's the sport that i'm
most familiar with recently but
previously you had crossfit is like matt
fraser most dominant crossfitter
basically ever he came into the sport
from weightlifting uh so you have people
that did uh analogous
sports
transferred across still had an
unbelievable speciality within their
their original domain but then
broadened themselves out and what you've
identified here is that you have an
equivalent with regards to
mma previously people would have perhaps
come from a very specialized background
be that wrestling or karate or boxing on
white eye and now you're going to have
people that are born and bred from the
very very beginning mma fighters do you
have any
sense or if you do you find it
particularly interesting that and then
also have you got any sense around
whether it is optimal to not specialize
in one particular domain versus to
become a generalist from the very
beginning have you thought about this
well i think uh you know if you look at
um
the statistics of our sport i think we
you know last time i need to this isn't
an accurate number so don't hold me to
this but last time i looked we had about
87 different ufc champions in history
and something like 53 of them were from
defined specialisms right whether they
are wrestlers or jujitsu players or a
kickboxer
those numbers obviously change now it's
kind of a couple of years since i saw
those numbers i just need to update
those but um i think if you look at
where the ufc has come from and look at
it as a whole
then yeah you can still say that there
isn't a true generalist that's rising to
the top it's still a sport that is built
on specialisms and usually those
specialisms are your x factor so if we
take israel out of sanya right now
obviously he's much reported as the best
striker ever in the ufc right he's a
clear kickboxer um
global to share obviously four years old
he's got to the top to be champion as a
jiu-jitsu guy right um so you know
there's still people that you can say
well that's a specialist um but i think
if you compartmentalize let's say the
last three years or the last five years
of our sport then you can start to see
where all right that guy has come
through purely an mma training approach
to success in our sport because again
it's become more popular as a sport it's
defined as an individual sport it's not
come from all the individual um styles
themselves so people just train in mma
now um
so that yeah if you look at the history
it still leans towards specialisms but
if you look at more current day and year
compartmentalize some of the more recent
success um
you know it's probably 50 50 is where
the specialists are to where the uh the
generic fighters or generalists are
one thing that's interesting the
difference between crossfit and mma that
i've just thought of there in crossfit
your your actual goal is to try and be
just
uh good at everything the goal is to not
lose any of the events that's the way
that you win the way that you win is to
be whatever top five to top 10 in every
single different event whereas in mma
the goal is to be acceptable across
everything so that you don't have any
weaknesses and then to be able to peak
within one particular domain that gives
you an outsized ability to finish the
fight right you're not going to win
you're going to be at more of a
vulnerability if you are good at
absolutely everything up against a
fighter that's acceptable at everything
and can push back most of your advances
but has one absolute freak dimension to
their game
yeah i mean
you can lose the olympic games in the
decathlon by having a crappy javelin
right and
if you can't throw the javelin very far
you can be great everything else but
that javelin is going to be the one
reason why you lose a gold medal or even
drop out of the medals same in our in
our sport right if you can't compete off
your back in jujitsu and someone takes
you to the ground like game over you
know
you have to have a level of generalism
to be able to survive right because the
fight can go to anyway it can go against
the fence it can go to the ground it can
be stand up in the middle of octagon you
know you can be in the clinch you can be
you know distance whatever so you know
you have to have some awareness of all
of those different types of things but
yes clearly people have got to the ufc
because they have an x factor something
that is like outstanding now whether
that is your
take down defense whether it's you take
down offense whether it's your striking
whether it's your grappling whatever
there's something that is just getting
you to the top which you would need to
maximize that potential and that's an x
factor which becomes a competitive
advantage so philosophically that's how
we try and approach up excuse me our
programming is that ultimately when
you're off camp when you're not in fight
camp preparation
we tailor all of our energies and our
efforts to
minimizing your limitations essentially
to raising the lowest hanging fruit like
what like what are the things that
potentially will lose you the fight when
we move into fight camp and now it's
peaking tapering and optimizing your
potential
we are sharpening the sword of your like
your your x factors so we we we pursue a
as a strength kind of strategy what are
your strengths and what are weaknesses
and when do we target those in the in
the distribution of your training plan
dude
it's so fascinating to to
see
a sport that didn't exist what 30 years
ago 30 like 31 32 years ago literally
didn't exist and now
where you guys are taking it to is
amazing
yeah no it's it's cool it's cool to be
around like i said it's 30 years as a
professional sport in 2023 so next year
um
and i still think you know there's
massive growth opportunities and
learnings and professionalization of the
sport and you know it's taking it to the
next level that is uh
it's it's it's a great sport to be
around right now it's uh it's still
growing and still improving
if there's someone who has found the
stuff that we're talking about here
particularly interesting what are some
of your favorite resources to keep up to
date with
work that's in your region that's in
strength and conditioning hypertrophy
you know like good accessible places
that people can read
yeah if there's any interest in uh you
know mma and then the ufc the ufc
performance institute has released uh a
digital journal which can be downloaded
um that's there's a link for that on our
um instagram pages and twitter pages and
things like that and again if you can't
navigate that just reach out through
those channels and we'll i'll let you
know um but again i think um you know
just looking at um
you know who who are the who the players
who who's making movements in the world
of strength conditioning right now you
know there's there's some some great
people out there phil darus doing some
good stuff obviously um joe defranco has
been doing it for a long time others you
know so it depends where you're coming
from and what you're trying to achieve
um whether it's mma specific or whether
it's more generic training cheers duncan
thank you so much for today mate
maurice thanks for the chat what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace